despite the stormy Daniel scandal
president Trump's popularity has
actually gone up did you know that it's
gone up yes it's gone up now here's this
interesting I read this article some
people are saying that because
evangelicals are supporting Donald Trump
they're actually helping to bring porn
into the mainstream they're saying that
evangelicals are helping normalize porn
yeah in response evangelicals say we're
in favor of any situation that makes
people scream Oh God it's just think
criticizes everyone the two people who
president Trump has not criticized on
Twitter are Vladimir Putin and stormy
Daniels the only two yeah of course
Trump was spanked in a hotel room by one
and then he had sex with stormy Daniels
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you thank you for applauding that
one so heartily the 2020 census is
asking a brand new question you may have
heard about this they're asking a brand
new question that many people say is
invasive and inappropriate yeah the
question is are you Gryffindor
Hufflepuff the big fuss what are you by
the way I I think I took that test twice
and a one time I was up up up and one
time I was ravenclaw so I'm a mix I
guess yeah
a hybrid yeah exotic yeah a new report
says that President Trump has been
hiring people for his administration
based on how they perform on television
yeah so ways the German congratulations
to our new Secretary of Housing and
Urban Development mr. Andy Richter
Hey
Kenny yeah what once they found out I
had Friday's off they were like sure
come on down
you